non-minimalists
i have a two-part question one is
what criteria do you use uh to make any
purchases
and the second question is what is your
opinion
on upgrading things that you currently
own
to you know something that you think
would make you happier
or something like that now ron i want to
get your your
thoughts on this but here are some
things i'll just set it up like this
because i have some definitive answers
for this quite often
people will call in and they'll ask a
rather esoteric question and that we
have to
try to work through it but we've already
written about this
quite a bit but here's here's the simple
answer for the first part of chris's
question
how do you decide how do you be more
intentional with your purchases
there are five questions that ryan and i
ask before we buy something
i'll go through those questions real
quick it's uh can i afford to part with
this money
and so i i think can i afford the thing
right it is is a question you know
obviously if i have to put on a credit
card i can't afford the things if i have
to finance it i can't afford the thing
and i know some people like what about
a car i gotta okay if you have to by
definition if you have to finance
something you can't afford it right
because you could afford it you would
just
pay cash right you would buy the thing
right so
so that's the first question the second
question is can i pay the actual cost
remember that the true
cost of a thing is well beyond the price
tag so
storing the thing cleaning the thing
changing the batteries or the oil and
the thing putting gas in the thing
the electricity for the thing the the
space that
it takes up in your mind all these
things are additional costs that
we don't think about because we see the
you know the the item we want to buy and
it's like oh it's 50 bucks
but it's not 50 bucks it's it's so much
more than that
because you have to worry about it you
have there's a psychological cause there
are all these other
costs will it add value to my life is
the next question
and really when we say will it add value
will serve a purpose or bring me joy
now you can justify anything so you can
pretend something's really going to
serve a purpose of bringing
but you have to be honest with yourself
with some of these things because
otherwise
we'll just let anything in right um
the fourth question is what are the
alternatives
and i think sometimes we don't even
think about that what
what else can i do with this money right
so if i'm going to spend 100 on a shirt
is that the best use of
of this money and then finally can i get
by without it for a while
i think it's one of the the messages of
minimalism here is if you didn't need it
five minutes
ago maybe you don't need it now and and
so
uh maybe i'll just wait a little bit and
we have another we have a rule
called the 30 30 rule if we if it costs
more than 30 bucks maybe i'll wait 30
hours it just try to put some time
between myself and the purchase so i'm
not making the
the impulse purchase so chris if you
want um we have a
a a wallpaper for your phone so you can
have all five of those questions
right there on your phone anytime you go
to make a purchase you're standing in
line somewhere
it's free over at the minimalists.com
wallpapers
uh but i do want to talk about this this
idea of upgrading with you ron
um and so because i know you've talked
about this in the past what are your
thoughts on on upgrades
oh it's a good question uh personally i
don't upgrade much of anything i'm still
rocking the iphone 6.
so if you ask most of the iphone fans
i'm
well behind the eight ball on that one
but i think when it comes to upgrades or
purchasing in general
um i try to look at it from a
perspective of who am i buying this for
my buying it for me or the other people
so a big thing for me why i started this
journey was kind of get away from
the idea of comparison and doing things
for other people i talked about in my
content how
i had this persona that i let go of this
mr smooth persona that
uh was given to me in high school and
that came with a lot of
additions of physical clutter the mental
clutter emotional clutter
things that i would just hold on to
because one i didn't know how to let it
go but two just trying to uphold this
vision or this standard of other people
had it for me so um
for me you know the question is who am i
buying this thing for so am i buying it
for me
or am i buying it for those that think i
need to have it or those that also have
it
isn't it funny though because we do that
to impress other people
but usually they don't even care they
don't we just think they do right we
don't
and that that's that's the the irony of
it all is because
we look for validation out of our
friendships our relationships
but then most times those friendship
relationships aren't genuine they're
just based on the things we own
so if you don't have those things you
don't have those relationships so i
think you need to build those first
and allow what you need in your life to
be what you need in your life absolutely
you know it's interesting uh you
mentioned the validation
i was having this conversation the other
day and there's actually a video you
talk about how
uh you kind of created this um
the the urge to live a simple life and
we'll probably get to that later but
the validation when we look at uh our
friends when we look at
our neighbors or the joneses we're
looking for validation in the wrong
place like we
we first have to validate ourselves like
that internal validation
that is what matters and if we don't
have that it's never going to be enough
from anywhere else but i'll tell you
what though i still have the i've got
the 5s
which i think came out after the six so
you're still like one one
you're still more minimalist why would
the 5s come out out after the six
i don't know but i'm pretty i'm pretty
sure it did but uh but any but anyway um
uh i was using that i was using that 5s
and someone was
they saw me use it they're like oh i
love that you have that old iphone
so if you hold on to it long enough it
actually becomes right
right it's ready i think the other thing
to add to that is
is we kind of you talked about
validation and there's a piece of my
content i talk about the reality check
that simple living and decluttering
gives us and there's a question that i
always pose
i say who would you be if you had
nothing but yourself in the mirror in
front of you
so if you had none of the the excessive
clutter or the things or the newest
phone or the
the you know the shoes the clothes just
you in the mirror who would you be
yeah and if you can't answer that
question then you're using those things
to define yourself yeah it doesn't
matter what you buy it doesn't matter
yeah it doesn't matter what vacation you
go on yeah
you can't look at yourself in the mirror
then yeah why does it matter yeah right
and
i mean i still get roasted all the time
for our documentary minimalism if you
see my apartment in there there's
i own next to nothing at the time now i
was a single guy at the time and and
when we filmed that and so things were a
little bit different you know i have a
family now and and that requires
different things as our life changes
and what i realized whenever even now
it's like during the pandemic they're
like
i bet those those minimalist guys
they're really regretting getting rid of
all their stuff
and it's like oh yeah i really missed
the broken waffle iron right and the old
bowling trophies
i didn't even know you bold yeah i mean
either i bought the bowling trophies
from goodwill
um and so like i i don't
what i realized there is like oh like
what they're saying is they would miss
the things and if so that's fine i'm not
i'm not here proselytizing i don't want
you to get rid of something if you're
completely contented
by the status quo then of course don't
don't deprive yourself of things but
maybe you can temporarily remove some
things from your life
for that short period of time and
realize like oh maybe the things i
thought were adding value to my life
are actually getting in the way of the
things that will add value to my life
chris i want to send you a copy of our
free ebook it's called
the minimalist rule book 16 rules for
living with less and one of those
rules is the don't upgrade rule
and we talk about some of the sometimes
you
if you do have to upgrade there are
three ways you can you can sort of go
without you can repair it or you replace
it
and so we talk about that don't upgrade
rule there are also some other rules in
there that will really
apply to you the 30 30 rule the 2020
rule the 90 90 rule
and a bunch of others that's free over
the minimalists.com
rule book i hope you enjoy that chris
can you men think of anything
that you've upgraded that you were like
i'm so glad i upgraded this
because i'm like really trying to find
that exception it depends so let's talk
about time frames real quick so
so i think in the moment usually the
answer to that is yes
like if you go yeah if i were to go to
the apple store right now
and they give me the iphone 13 or
whatever the new thing is
in the moment i'm gonna be like yes that
new box there's something about that new
box
yeah taking off the shrink wrap like
right but that's that's that
that's the dopamine speaking right but
as soon as i walk out
it instantly begins to diminish and a
day later it might still be
there but it has been fleeting for an
entire 24 hours
a month two months six months later it's
like oh i don't even care about this
right
and then two years later it's like oh
this stupid old phone
and and so i think it really depends on
on the time frame
you're talking about usually i i think
that that that sort of
consumer high does not last far past the
checkout line
you could tweet that podcast sean
you